is it okay to be 28 and still buy wheat
from a high school kid
[Applause]
[Music]
in that bag
something i assume you did not do
here's something that great it's crazy
you can't really see it but this
gentleman right here after his beers
instead of giving it back to the weight
they've been crushing it has crushed
them and put them in this
are you are you the mayor of this town
sir
he's like that's 35 cents [ __ ]
goddamn deposits
grab
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
where's brendan f
[Music]
you better remember your nurse's name
too goddammit
brandon where are you at
hey don't let us down man okay
just tell me you're a pediatrician or
something like that
he's not an actual doctor relax
he's looking for free healthcare right
here that's all
he's looking for that school nurse hey
where's she
who are you here with brendan
what's up buddy who are you here with
your two friends what kind of work do
you do brother i'm an id guy very nice
what'd you give me your saps i took an
act i got like a 21. that's fantastic
i like that
just keeps on [ __ ] straight
that's not that good
that's not good
it's out of like 38 or something
i don't know what they are and i just
wanted to sound smart
[Applause]
ah that guy's yelling it's average the
zombie's looking good
that's a median score for the half-dead
people
scotty pippen's favorite salad dressing
ranch
[Applause]
what kind of bed do you have brother you
got a king a queen
a queen is it against the wall or in the
middle of the room
and what are your what do your buddies
do for a living
[Music]
what's up buddy
we're at
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're a drug dealer
target macy's bent back through the tax
rate
that's like having a twitter and saying
you work for elon musk
part time right now part time it's
nights and weekends when i'm trying to
go full time
i wouldn't rather you say freelance
it makes sense brendan's question is is
it garbage if your friends paid you for
tonight's comedy show ticket with weed
[Applause]